I remember what you did they remember -
you were the reason that we were all
there it happened because of you and you
can't tell anyone why would you it is
your fault
hi okay all right then all of it
hello everyone my name is markiplier and
welcome to five nights at candy's 3 now
I'm meant to get to this sooner but I
got trapped in Boston due to the
blizzard I know I said that many times
but I wasn't able to get to this game
until I returned it how are you feeling
today I'm pretty good it's been two
weeks I understand that it was a very
traumatic experience but luckily your
brother wasn't seriously hurt you have
to remember they weren't real they were
just machines they aren't capable of
harming anyone what happened was just an
accident
he was just broken or my brother or the
machine but it's ok now you're safe here
you remembered them from the theater is
the old one that you and your father
went to a year ago right your father has
told me about what happened while you
were there you got separated from each
other that day when the incident
happened have you still had nightmares
since we last met were they about those
monsters you drew for me oh you're a
very creative girl thank you but you
can't let your fears take control of
your imagination in order for your
nightmares to end you have to face your
fears I don't know if I want to do that
you have to face the monsters again
don't think that's a good idea
show them that you're not afraid how do
I do that what I'm peeing my pants in
front of them
do you understand no not at all it's the
only way now Mary I need you to try and
remember what happened on that day a
year ago okay I'll try real hard whoever
you are I don't know who I'm talking to
but oh ah
good I'm a creative little girl that has
no eyeballs whoa hey aren't you even
gonna say hello are you the you the cat
thing hello it's me I'm the origami cat
how am I here you're dreaming right now
sort of at least this room you're in
your old room from before you move right
now it looks like you barely remember it
you've had a lot of nightmares lately
right well that's why I'm here I have a
couple of tricks to fighting the
monsters remember a few years ago you
got trouble sleeping almost every night
No why does everyone want me to remember
my past I don't get it so your dad gave
you a cassette tape player with a paint
with quiet music and he made for you so
you could sleep I bet it would also help
me with sleeping better now the other
thing is the monsters hate life so I
suggest flashing live in their eyes
whenever you can
oh yeah that's good boy just wave my
flashlight in their face unless they're
under your bed listen before you figure
such a came he come to the business side
there are
and go back up the opposite direction
turning our back will lure them out from
under the bed listen closely to the
sound of the boom face back towards the
opposite end of the room again give them
a good like enjoys now go look for the
tape player I'll stay here if you need
my help
once again you told me I was in dream
what would go getting a tape player my
dream do for me mr. cat man how is that
gonna make me any better at fighting the
monster tape player should be somewhere
up ahead you should try and go and look
for it
I want to go to bed no no you won't
stand a chance against the monster
please you should go search for the
people there it will definitely help you
all right fine kitty made of paper cuz
your origami I'm gonna go do this oh
[Music]
this is thanks Kate this way your
deepest memories are I'm talking to you
from the dreams I see those glowing
particle things they make up pay players
should be somewhere ahead just remember
to stay on the path so the shadows can't
editing if you get lost and give you
back
only if you're on the path I can't reach
you if you're out in the darkness let me
know get back by pressing are you mean
this darkness
hey well that didn't work out for me
I was just wanting to test the theory of
the darkness there's a lot different
than I expected to be in I like it
beware of the shadows stay on the path
alrighty then I'll be aware of the
shadows but did okay here we go
maybe I shouldn't run that seems to be
making noise dudu dudu Lulu look look
the oh hello there's nothing on the back
oh ok all right steady B check out the
back of it the path does not necessarily
lead to every destination good to know
at this dead-end that I'm at ooh I love
the sea of darkness surrounding me
reminds me of the darkest is dark
darkness in my own soul I feel good way
of Sandwich what is that whoa hey slow
down there it's you my old friend I
thought that you had forgotten about me
it's been kind of boring in air there's
a mushroom for racing around in the toy
box
I remember back when we used to have a
race every day those lots of fun we
should totally do that again sometime oh
well I think you didn't come all the way
over here time for me you should get
what you came for and then hurry back to
sick day if you have anything to say say
now I don't know do you have anything to
say say no huh I got nothing to say to
you you stay down in that toy box where
I put you if you'll talk to me you
didn't win me no races oh I feel bad
though I shouldn't yell at my old
clothes my old toys are good to me hello
a part of a newspaper article read it
sure after closing so soon the brand-new
wire animatronics were sent back to
rumors are circulating that the
animatronics will be used as a base for
newer designs of advanced fully mobile
animatronics which are speculated to be
used for a future project
we talking about five nights at freddys
good yeah what we're talking about we
might be talking about that I really
like this though it was like I just
expected it to be like the demo over and
over again but this is this is like
original and interesting do not be
afraid of stepping slightly off the path
step too far away from the path however
and that is when you should be afraid
all righty then
only know to do also why is this past so
wet I mean I I don't appreciate it
raining inside of my own head because
again this is my dream you think I'd be
able to control it a part of a newspaper
article read it at the closing so soon
the brand-new wire animatronics percent
backed up okay this is the same one as
before of advanced fully mobile
animatronics which are speculated to be
used for a future breath that's the
exact same thing why they have the same
thing twice
peculiar unless there was some specific
reason for that but I can't understand
what it would be oh well that just keeps
printing off into the darkness hello is
it found arcade game number one found
the tape player good now I can hurry
back I think I suppose and hopefully
death will not wait for me when I'm
coming home hopefully the origami cat
isn't there to actually kill me even
though the origami cat seemed to be
giving me some good advice about how to
survive resumed ever I mean obviously he
was giving me advice about the specific
scenario of the bedroom which i think is
where the majority of this game is going
to take place but I appreciate the
backstory like it's interesting to know
that there's something to this character
and something that tied together all the
other games because to be perfectly
frank I don't remember a lot of story
out of the other games all I remember is
that they were a pretty good
come on trying to be warned that's what
I can appreciate great you found you
remember how to cue MIT the tape player
yes you push the play button
SuperDuper good luck with the nightmare
okay thank you wow that seems a little
passive-aggressive okay all right could
you punch me in the face before I go to
bed that make me feel better
all right let's snooze it up about my
race cars oh here we go then I if I
remember the demo correctly this is
going to be a time oh I'm ready I'm so
ready but it's so interesting because
remember to use a tape player the time
goes twice as fast when it plays it's
just really interesting because it means
it means that like there's some
honest-to-goodness factor it's me Oh
back when I had red hair in a pink
mustache all right I remember correctly
I have to be pretty active oh hey well
there's always there hello
I can't hate him whoo I remember this
we're always there okay but I don't
think I'll have to be too quick on the
first night the only thing that I'm
expecting though is it maybe there's
going to be more animatronics lurking
for me in the darkness hello how are you
good I boot my nose can I put my
adorable nose
no can I move anything's nose you you
want a bubble nose anybody got a
bootable nose over here yeah okay three
wine please be kind rewind okay hello
OOP your nose your nose I don't like the
hey where'd you come from up oh yeah you
think you're gonna get away from me this
time I'm I've learned a thing or two
about where your face is and how to
shine on it
call me the shanty okay I remember how
to do this and seems like it's gone for
now and it seems like this is going to
be just as painful as it was before
all right soothes me to sleep with your
sweet lie send me off to lala land
knowing that I'm not going to be
horribly mauled by a giant road and also
this is a really clever animatronic and
how the hell did you get in my closet
I don't like Annie I think is a bad
adventure for me a little girl to
experience also am i feel like current
time am I talking to that therapist
person now or am I just kind of reliving
some horrible memories of me having too
many closets oh god is this symbolic or
something I don't want to know
ah [ __ ] was that something I could have
sworn I saw something creeping out of
the corner of that doorway but now I'm
not 100% too sure about that that's
that's no good all right I move twice
pow okay hey how's it going because in
the other five nights at candy's Games
there were other animatronics on I think
these these might have been the ones oh
my god
when do these kids get any sleep do they
ever sleep I mean with five nights at
Freddy's 4 it was an acceptable medium
that maybe it was all a lie and you were
in a hospital because your frontal lobe
had been bitten off and you're only
stuck in a perpetual world of nightmares
until you would hope to either wake up
or die that was legitimately the story
of five nights at Freddy's 4 did you
guys know that that is quite literally
the story there's a lot of clues spread
around in five minutes at Freddy's 4
[Music]
hey hey no don't want something no no
yeah yet you know I really wonder if
there's a way to win this because I did
all my time playing today in the dark
I've never actually have kids do that
[Music]
yeah I really don't know if there's a
way to actually win that because holy
[ __ ] I think it just doesn't make a
whole lot of sense yeah all right but I
got to keep scanning a lot faster
because barely he's really douchey and
if this was the first night and what the
hell is in store for me later cuz
goddamn this death surrounded me at
every corner and by death I mean just
one giant mouse holy [ __ ]
okay but yeah anyways so five nights at
Freddy's 4 that was the story of a kid
like it was obviously told in all of the
the the cutscenes build the 8-bit
cutscenes the kid was being tormented by
his brother in a facility where he
thought death and destruction was all
around him hey and I'm not a hundred
percent sure but they they alluded to
this dream theory like I believe that
Scott had like this continuous theorem
between all of the different games that
suggested they all spawned from the mind
of a child those are may not be the
exact words but they're pretty close and
so in this along the same veins the
therapist talking about how the kid
shouldn't let her fears conquer her
imagination are these things real are
they really here stalking a little girl
in her bedroom at night and maybe in her
paranoia and lack of sleep she just
doesn't know how to handle the monsters
up I've got the monstrous to keep her
awake at night how do you handle this
because I remember as a kid I had
nightmares all the time I still do I
have nightmares pretty much every other
night I have
nightmare and it's gotten to the point
where I've just gotten used to it so
much it doesn't really faze me but as a
kid I had nightmares all the time and
they were vivid with vividly real like
incredibly real every single night I
would wake up from something scaring me
in my dreams and I mean not everything
but every other yeah you're I got a
story to tell here I'm trying to open my
soul about my childhood you're just
sitting here like oh that's not normal
you're a weirdo named G like that side I
just rewind the doodad okay oh yeah like
very frequently and I remember one more
distinctly than any other I was a pretty
typical nightmare I was being chased by
someone with a chainsaw I must have been
like seven or eight at the time maybe
nine but I was being chased by someone
with a chainsaw and it was uh it was
really freaky because for some reason I
was running but I could see its face
very clearly like just this huge angry
face just burned into my mind and then I
woke up
but the terrifying the terrifying thing
was I could still see that face that
face was literally burned into my eyes
when I looked in my doorway in front of
my bed at the foot of my bed I saw his
face nothing else not his body not the
chainsaw just his face staring at me
from the doorway
it was the most chilling spirit I threw
my head under the covers like I I hid I
thought I was gonna die I I Cour din
fear and again I'm a child to win her
child you see something horrible like
that just a figment of your own
imagination come to terrorize you
it's real I did and I remember that like
I will remember that till the day I died
because it was by far the scariest
nightmare I've ever had and then I have
nightmares every night and what's even
weirder is that my nightmares are
sometimes recurring like I will I'll
have nightmares in the exact same place
and when I'm in the dream I will
remember the nightmare but not the fact
that it's a dream like hey hey buddy
shove it a shoe so hard alright alright
one more time before the end of the
night oh you love that ok cool it's gone
for now great good no all right cool so
yeah even if it's day I'll have
nightmares in the exact same places that
I've been before multiple times I can't
even count how many times because I
barely remember the nightmares when I
get out of it but some just stand it so
vividly in my mind like that one from my
childhood and gasps it's kind of late
even before I started playing horror
games I mean that's why when I first
started being a youtuber I was I
honestly was very hesitant to play or
games just because like I was very
scared I just was yeah we did it we beat
the first night and then you know but in
a way playing horror games kind of
helped me conquer my fear but they're
still there
Oh God
hello uh uh where are we now yeah hello
yeah mom oh I can tell we're related
because we have no eyes I'll be over
here playing with knives and such maybe
some lasers staff area employees only oh
I'm not at home okay then
oh hello Stacey is it I haven't seen the
puppeteer topic yet I've heard that it's
a big passion for the mouse - is that
what it is
well I see you over there don't think
you can hide from me okay then oh you're
free
hi sweetie are you having fun hope
you're happy with the place I picked out
it's just the two of us
while your brother is in camp being
inside well we should have for dinner
tonight okay
I don't have to go that's the boys
restroom
[Music]
I got a bad feeling about this
these arcade games are so boring I want
ask the rat if we could get some new
ones soon
Benny got a bit angry the rat is a real
jerk okay whack-a-mole
jungle pinball Astro pinball yeah hey
kid on the rap nicely yeah hey let's
talk about nerve event on behind me oh
yeah I do yeah
you're right okay here count your hungry
backstage employees only okay all right
I'm gonna play hide and seek with the
RAI that's good are you looking for a
good hiding spot right hiding under the
one of the tables these tables oh one of
the Oh
whoops I went the long way around
whoopsie doopy I'm gonna go hide under
one of the tables apparently hey you
guys got a good hiding spot right under
these tables hide under the table sure
okay oh hey I found you all righty then
thank you that's good game I don't know
if there was a spot that I could have
actually won that but maybe there was so
anyway that's the first night I am like
the other five nights at candy's games
I'm gonna do a full playthrough of it
and I'm actually very eager about this
one because it does put a lot more
emphasis on the backstory and gives the
world some fleshed out nature because
that's a lot of things that these five
nights at Freddy's fan game myths
with giving themselves a universe and
they kind of did it you know and a
half-assed
oh that's in the title it's just what it
is way but this is creating something
and I like it and it's good so I'll be
eager to play more of it so thank you
everybody so much for watching a meal
knock Oh congratulations through the
great game I like I'll put a link is
well for everybody out there to play the
banks again and as always I'll see you
in the next video bye bye
[Music]